You're so funny. And I realized, I like, that's so.
Hard to find. Cause I, you know, if I were in college,
I feel like it would be a little bit easier, but I'm going full,
full blown into music. So, um, I,
I miss it so much just being able to have that many
musicians at your fingertips and just is so nice.
Um, when your relationship with your coaches,
are they really like checking in every day? Or is that just when the TV see,
this is an NDA.
I'm worried about that. No, don't worry if don't work away around,
but I want to say, I know you don't know how bad I want to talk about
[inaudible].
Yeah. Okay. We always assume everything is done for the camera, right? Yeah.
Correct. Babe.
We assume that the only time that the coaches get in contact with you at the
time when the cameras are on that,
there really is no true interpersonal relationship where they're like,
I'm going to foster. I'm really going to help this kid grow into the artist.
Well, no, I will say this. I will say this.
There are times when that does happen. Okay.
There are, there are. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I know.
No, you don't have to confirm nor deny. We're just telling you what. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
But there's no way that the positive, positive.
Positive.
But like, um, you know, I know this is not happening.
You wake up and Blake Shelton is texting you, going, you ready today, boy.
Right? You're like, nah, bro. You know that part of the bridge,
I still don't have my falsetto. Right. And Blake's going,
I'll be ready that boy, get some warm,
clean lungs and get it or whatever that doesn't happen.
Right. He doesn't text you confirm or deny nor deny. Here's another thing.
Right? Um, another thing. Yeah. Another thing is,
is that I feel like some coaches are better than others. Like for me,
I think that Kelly Clarkson, although she wasn't on your year, Kelly Clarkson,
I feel like it was a good coach. I feel like she would actually call her.
I think she calls. I think she calls.
Well, I can say this Miley Cyrus.
I feel like she does all over it all over every single person on her team was
like taken care of. She had emails sending back.
That's why with Jess Freeman on your season was
insane. Passed away just recently.
Why did you bring that up? I know I got all sad bumps on my body.
Okay. What other assumptions? Janice freemen. Okay.
Not only incredible. One of our favorites, um,
just to win in my opinion, don't make me cry right now. 100%. No.
If you're going.
Based off of talent alone,
but there's a whole backside to her just as a person just hanging out with her,
just meeting her. She is so freaking powerful. Like it's a,
it's an energy. It's not even just like the way she like talks.
And I'm not saying this just to, just to say it like for real,
it's like you can ask anybody that, that knew her. She was.
Well,
here's how I know the reason how I know why she was powerful and a nice person.
Is that because Miley, when Jen has passed away.